the New York Times ran a story about how
the trouble administration is doing and
it's dark
literally Trump aids are reportedly so
unfamiliar with the White House that
they have meaning from the dark because
they can't find the light switches even
said even sadder Trump apparently splits
his time between sitting around in his
bathrobe watching TV and giving
inaccurate tours of the Oval Office he
told one visitor that the offices golden
drapes were used by FDR but they were
actually made for Bill Clinton and that
should be really easy to remember
because they threw out all the White
House fabrics after Clinton got rid of
him like get Isaac Bernie Bernie and it
shows Trump said the article was just
lies tweeting failing New York Times
writes total fiction concerning me
they've gotten it wrong for two years
and now they're making up stories and
sources then he went back to watching
Fox News on a TV George Washington built
this amazing
what does another fake White House facts
Donald Trump tells us towards one
function all the water fountains are
whites-only
all right
which are alan tudyk the Lincoln Bedroom
is named after our greatest president
president bedroom yes in the bedroom
underrated